las aguas del río grande el último tramo
de un largo y peligroso viaje que en la
gran mayoría de los casos culmina sin el
final esperado para los migrantes en la
frontera sur las autoridades
estadounidenses continúan deportando
amparados en el llamado título 42 pero
no las pidieron explicaciones nada de
los gringos nada
y si legalmente si quisiéramos que el
presidente by the law de una oportunidad
de estar en estados donde y dos poros el
título 42 en vigencia desde la
administración de donald trump permite
expulsar de manera rápida a los
migrantes irregulares basándose en el
argumento de un riesgo a la salud
pública en medio de la pandemia a pesar
de ser una administración demócrata con
promesas de un trato más humano a los
migrantes el gobierno de joe biden la
mantiene en vigor y las deportaciones se
hacen ahora también por vía aérea el
título 42 impide que personas y familias
tengan acceso a procedimientos de asilo
y de identificación de sus necesidades
de protección en eeuu la expulsión de
eeuu al sur de méxico aumenta el riesgo
de devolución en cadena de personas
vulnerables en peligro la acnur denuncia
el posible peligro para las personas de
vuelta a sus países de origen además de
poner al límite la capacidad de países
como méxico o guatemala andrés manuel
lópez obrador presidente de méxico y
kamala harris vicepresidenta y encargada
en coordinar la respuesta a la crisis
migratoria de estados
buscan ampliar su cooperación para
mitigar las causas de la migración
centroamericana su reciente conversación
telefónica abordó temas que se ampliarán
en la cumbre de diálogo económico el 9
de septiembre en washington